I'm putting together a team,
people with special abilities and see,
I believe enemies are coming
right there.
I'm in are now that the justice league
trailer is out and it has jokes.
It was a lot of talk about dcs course
correction as if the overly grim tone of
Batman v Superman was the key to why
wasn't that good of a movie,
but from my point of view,
Zack Snyder could make justice league
and out and out comedy and it still
wouldn't fix what I see as a more
fundamental problem in his filmmaking.
Something that's really apparent in
Batman versus superman.
His preoccupation,
his obsession with moments,
the expense of scenes.
What do I mean by this?
Well,
let me start by saying this movie
moments are awesome.
Really great moment can be transcendent.
They can leave deep lifelong visual
impressions on a film goer.
They can come to represent a whole new
category of feeling.
That's why film geeks like me reference
them so much in conversation with
friends when you were a film student,
at least when I was a film student.
That's what makes things exciting.
Most of the student films I directed
revolved around a few moments that I
thought were going to blow people away.
If I could just navigate the story
there,
that would be enough.
The moment would do all the work.
Then I just navigate to the next one.
For this reason,
my student films weren't that good.
Batman v Superman,
dawn of justice,
I think suffers from a similar problem.
Zack Snyder is obviously obsessed with
moments.
The movie is chock full of that moments
when time is slowed down in the
composition is just right moments when
the score swells in the film tries to
broadcast a single message.
A lot of people talk about Snyder as a
great visual stylist will.
Of course he is.
That's where all the focus goes toward
crafting moments.
They say his character,
his lack motivation.
Of course they do because all character
motivations are subservient to the
films.
Own motivation to reach the next moment.
It makes sense then that Snyder puts
extraordinary care into.
Montage is twice in this film,
the opening credits featuring Batman's
origin story and at the 44 minute mark,
spotlighting superman's more impressive
heroics.
We have slow motion moment montage,
plus there are something like 40 shots
in these montages together and they all
aim to be iconic.
I think of Snyder could make a whole
movie like this.
He would.
Oh wait,
he already did.
Yes.
It's also why he favors dream sequences
and flashbacks.
More excuses to show more moments.
What that meant,
superman really lacks is scenes.
Actual scenes,
not just filler between moments.
Scenes are hard to define since they're
so malleable.
It's hard to say what one is,
but what a good scene does is dissolve
the actors and the soundstage and the
costumes and makeup and camera angle
into a living and breathing reality.
We should be a strong sense of place,
of feeling,
of possibility that the characters who
inhabit the space could go anywhere
within it,
even if they don't.
Even if you know that the technicalities
of lighting and blocking wouldn't let
them.
In other words,
the discreet elements that make up a
good scene should not feel like they're
in service to something else.
Even though they are too often in Batman
v Superman,
the characters feel awkwardly placed in
their scenes.
I mean,
does anyone get the sense that Clark
Kent,
Lois Lane or Perry white actually spend
time as a daily planet?
We visit the daily planet eight times in
the movie,
but the longest scene there is only a
minute and 11 seconds.
The rest are under a minute and half are
under 30 seconds.
This doesn't feel like a place.
It feels like a fraction of a location
where people say things like this.
When the planet was founded,
it stood for something period.
The Bat Cave and Clark's apartment,
Lex Luthor is office.
The kryptonians ship all have the same
issue and that's just about the extent
of the settings that we visit more than
once in the film.
What's more of these scenes are filmed
largely in medium shots,
closeups or extreme closeups,
which makes it even harder to ground the
scenes or for the audience to ground
itself within them.
When in all these places,
we spend an awful lot of time looking at
screens.
There's also very little distinction
between metropolis and Gotham,
the two cities that sculpted their
respective heroes.
If you're looking for a metaphor for the
whole film,
Note,
the fact that one of the longest scenes
takes place on an abandoned island
between the two cities that the heroes
completely destroyed.
Building a good scene isn't only about
location,
it's about fitting the dialogue,
the tone and the characters into that
location and endowing it with a sense of
duration.
Avengers,
age of ultron,
from last year.
It isn't a perfect movie,
but there's a great story about how just
and fought to keep the Hawkeye farmhouse
scene in the film that slow paced,
confident,
seen runs for a full 16 minutes right in
the middle of the action and when you're
there,
you're not waiting to go somewhere else.
You're there learning about the
characters and when those characters
have their moments later in the film,
they land with poignancy.
Of course,
almost all films,
especially Superhero blockbusters,
are going to have expositional scenes
and scenes that set up future action and
in great movies,
all the scenes often work together to
participate in an overarching tone or a
complex message.
But great scenes function as their own
little universes within a film and good
movies should have plenty of them.
That meant be superman runs for two and
a half hours with a heaping helping of
big moments,
and yet I don't quite feel like I've
been anywhere.
The scene is where all is loaded into
the chamber.
Firing the gun without loading can only
result in empty noise,
a bang,
but no impact.
I'm always hopeful about new superman
movies because superman is so important
to me,
but I won't let some Batman Jokes and
upbeat rock music.
For me,
light heartedness isn't the basic
problem that needs to be fixed here.
The overused and unearned moment is DC's
greatest foe.
Hey guys,
you know I.
I couldn't resist doing a video on
superman.
I just can't resist.
There's a new nerdwriter video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right there and click that
subscribe to this channel,
you'll get all of them.
That really helps me out and I gotta
think squarespace.
We're helping to sponsor this video.
It helped to fund this Shanell without
interfering in the content,
which is just so awesome.
They make sleek,
intuitive websites.
You don't have to know coding.
If you sign up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and if
you use the offer code
nerdwriter@squarespace.com,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase,
which is cool if you want to make a
website.
Thank you guys so much.
I'll see you next Wednesday.